hi so welcome this video this is a
special one to my channel because we are
well I've got a guest with me for one
thing this is Hannah who is the host of
science how an expression of that would
mean yes and what we're going to do
today is we're going to with showcasing
electricity yes in a terrifying manner
we've got one of these cameras in the
left-foot shot machines and we're going
to be not doing some questions on
electricity and the person you get it
wrong gets an electric shock every time
it's not going to be nice question
community question sir
so in the UK what boat is to be
generated by an adult electric eel 120
volts
next girl proximately how many times per
second
I need to base losing streak condition
good question yeah
during the Apollo 13 mission battery
from the lunar module we used to provide
powder after explosion in the service
module what voltage did the Apollo
spacecraft uses while you stayed six
hours focusing voltage or current
voltage
you planted finance okay you get first
question expressed more country was the
famous electrical inventor Nikola Tesla
warning
Savion touching modern country or the
country will stem eruption and correct
answer in the villagers knew later in
the Austrian Empire which is now
modern-day croatia even though he is
serving but I would say enhancing the
closest answer from the public is he
serving they all inside of you
- Teresa you may in milliamps what is
the smallest DC currents that have cuz I
feel through that skin 15 sorry I feel
really bad this is just means I'm
whipping boy next question the things we
do for science
so the first scientist to study our
trusty was the ancient recording
observations that the activity while
rubbing amber proximately wet in 350 BC
doctors 600
you should not be enjoying this so much
because I think I think you enjoy it I
can shot next question please
okay these two two four four Tesla is a
minor planet was there as an asteroid
well thanks very much for watching we we
learned things about two if you fancy
learn more about electricity we have our
special on the science our expression at
them bits to Beijing 7:00 until 8:00 UK
time and we have shows every Tuesday
sometime yes it's just before Christmas
yeah and then we already have all our
shows on top mixed class but the link on
screen right now and we also have our
most recent shows when I SoundCloud as
well so you can check all those out
thanks very much what you can done
actually we'll see on our radio shows